So, ich muss erst nochmal einen zweiten Rechner anmachen.
Also ich sehe noch keinen Chat oder sonst was.
Weil doch, ich habe hier eine Vorschau.
Ich muss nochmal einen Streaming-Rechner anmachen.
Sonst sehe ich nämlich überhaupt nichts.
Aber ich habe mir gedacht, nachdem Twitch ja eh immer eine ganze Weile braucht, bis Notifications rausgehen, dann machen wir das jetzt schon mal an.
Passwort vertippt.
Ich hoffe jetzt richtig.
Ich könnte bis mein Rechner gestartet ist, kann ich auf dem Tablet gucken.
Mal sehen, was im Chat passiert, falls schon jemand am Start ist.
Ist schon jemand am Start?
Und haben wir zufällig Quality-Options?
Das muss ich jetzt doch gerade mal nachgucken hier auf dem Tablet.
Ja, das ist ein bisschen der Nachteil, wenn man seine Festplatte voll verschlüsselt hat.
Was ich als komplett paranoider Informatiker natürlich habe.
Dauert ein bisschen, bis die Rechner gestartet sind.
Wublox.
Kanäle.
Da ist er.
Bis ich das im Tablet eingegeben habe, ist mein Rechner auch gestartet.
Guck mal, das hat noch nicht mal erkannt, dass ich angeblich online bin.
Ah, egal.
Jetzt rechne eh an.
Oh, die Tastatur wieder umstöpseln.
Wie kann man Weihnachtsmusik anmachen?
Ist ja schon kurz davor.
So, Chrome aufmachen.
Jetzt sehe ich gleich was.
So, jetzt habe ich auch Chat.
Also, wenn schon einer da ist.
Jetzt sehe ich euch.
Jetzt habe ich Chat.
Jetzt haben wir Quality-Options.
Wir haben Quality-Options.
Alter.
Twitch will es wissen, ey.
Ja, da habe ich ja noch weniger Grund, Partner zu werden.
Außer Twitch-Money.
Wenn ich jetzt auch so schon immer Quality-Options kriege.
Die Musik geht mir auf den Sack.
Haben wir nicht sonst was?
Oh, wir mussten ja noch.
Ich habe es euch ja gestern versprochen, ja.
Dass wir Till Lindemann Features Haftbefehl gucken.
Ja.
Da müssen wir jetzt noch durch, ja.
Ich weiß nicht so genau, was mich da erwartet.
Was ist mit der Maus los?
Fuck.
Was ist das?
So, ich muss jetzt den Sound, glaube ich, ein bisschen lauter machen.
Dass man die Kickstarter-Videos hört.
So, machen wir schon mal ein Spiel darauf.
Und dann konnte man, wie konnte man den Kram jetzt ordentlich filtern?
Das ist, ich finde die Kickstarter-Seite ist teilweise ein bisschen sortiert nach weitere
Filter.
Man konnte das nämlich sortieren.
Nach Spiele-Hardware, nach Spiele-Software, nach quasi Offline-Spielen und sowas.
Projekte, Beiträge sortieren nach Zufall.
Oh, wo ging das denn jetzt nochmal?
Ah, hier.
Hardware-Videospiele.
Spiele.
Moment.
Videospiele.
Da.
Handy-Spiele.
Igitt.
Es gibt eine eigene Kategorie für Handy-Spiele.
Ah, man kann keine Tabs aufmachen.
Na gut.
Dann fangen wir heute mal an mit Hardware für Videospiele.
Und es geht los.
Ja.
Es geht los.
Haha.
Geht schon gut los.
Der erste performance-verbessernde Gaming-Handschuh.
Was?
Nicht alles gibt es.
Ok.
Ja.
Da gucken wir aber nur mal drüber.
Weil eigentlich, ähm.
Eigentlich will ich ja Videospiele gucken.
Hier.
Also.
Da.
Die Kategorie.
Warte mal.
Wo ist sie wieder?
Ist versteckt.
Hier.
Da.
Gummis Bow.
Da ist die Kategorie.
Ja.
Wow.
So, ich poste den ganzen Krempel nochmal kurz auf Twitch, äh, auf Twitter.
Die Streammusik kann sich nicht entscheiden.
Guck mal, ich hab die schon übelst geboostet, die Streammusik, ey.
Man weiß nicht, Windows und Sound verträgt sich eh nicht so gut.
Ist eigentlich mein Titel richtig?
Kickstarter Projekt 2019, ja, das passt.
Oh ne, ich hab wieder indische Tastatur.
Ich wollt grad sagen, warum schreibt ihr auf Twitter so merkwürdige Zeichen?
Mein Windows stellt sich immer, hier hab ich's mittlerweile gefixt, ne, aber, ähm,
beim anderen Rechner hab ich teilweise auch immer indische Tastatur eingestellt.
Ich weiß nicht warum, nicht, dass ich jemals indische Tastatur installiert hätte.
So.
Tweet ist raus.
Was, was sagen denn die Twitter-Trends?
Guten Rutsch.
Äh, sind die nicht ein bisschen früh?
KronkTV, Biathlon, GZS, ääh, was, äh, alles Trends.
So schlimm.
Es trendet der kleine Lord.
Und irgendwie hab ich grad schon wieder gleich Drachenlord gelesen.
Nicht, dass mich das auch nur ansatzweise interessieren würde, was bei der ganzen Geschichte
läuft, aber, ähm, man sieht's, man sieht's halt oft auf Twitter.
Moin Leute.
Ja, also, äh, ihr wisst doch, ich bin ein bisschen nervös.
Wart, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte,
warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte,
Man sieht es halt oft auf Twitter.
Moin Leute.
So, ähm,
jetzt gucken, ah, noch was zu trinken am Start.
Also ich glaube, wir müssen dann eh die Musik ausmachen,
weil wir Kickstarter-Videos gucken.
Also, was geht's denn?
Sekunde.
Oh, ganz wichtig.
Ganz wichtig, ich hab ja was.
Ich hab ja was Essentielles vergessen.
Was ganz wichtiges
hab ich vergessen zu starten.
Ohne geht's ja schon mal gar nicht.
Nämlich
die Web-Application 11.
Ohne die Web-Application 11
läuft nix hier.
Web-Application 11, beste.
Was hab ich jetzt?
Jetzt hab ich auch noch falsch gestartet,
die Web-Application 11.
So, wenn ich jetzt Glück hab,
reagiert Visual Studio mal wieder.
Und wenn ich Pech hab,
wow,
alter Visual Studio nervt doch nicht so rum.
Was ist denn hier los schon wieder?
Ich hab's extra ohne Debugging
gestartet.
Ja, wenn ich was ohne Debugging
starte, Visual Studio,
dann erwarte ich...
Was ist das? Warum hängt denn das?
Was ist denn da schon wieder los?
Unable to connect.
Tja, das ist eben mein Problem.
Dann lass ich Visual Studio halt auf.
Da hab ich drauf.
Ich darf drauf. Nice.
Nice.
Easy.
Funktioniert alles.
Jetzt die Musik abgekackt.
Das war zu viel.
Oh, ja, wir können übrigens,
also wie gesagt,
wir können Weihnachtsmusik anmachen,
wenn es euch danach ist.
Ich hab mir extra was rausgesucht,
was nicht so nervig ist.
Relaxing.
Ich glaub, das ist zu relaxing.
Aber den hier war wieder an.
Das ist auch,
auch schon ganz schön relaxing.
Wir brauchen was nicht ganz so relaxing.
Hip-Hop-Beats.
Nee, das ist,
das ist zu, zu wir.
Christmas-Hip-Hop-Radio.
Ich weiß nicht.
Wie ist denn so die Lautstärke von dem?
Nee, das ist ja auch,
das ist ja nervig.
Chill-Out-Radio, das klingt doch gut.
Ja, gut.
Ob das jetzt da irgendwie über die Kühe fliegen,
ist mir jetzt lebensrechtlich.
Guck mal, meine Maus ist übelst kaputt.
Habt ihr es gesehen?
Ich klicke hier rein, ziehe das hoch und dann trackt,
YouTube mal wieder verbuggt.
Lull.
Aber das ist ja nichts Neues.
Kann ich sogar wieder ein bisschen leiser machen.
Easy.
Achso, easy.
Was hast du für eine Maus und Tastatur?
Ich habe eine,
nachdem ich die letzten,
letzten paar Jahre für meine Verhältnisse viele Mäuse ausprobiert habe,
bin ich jetzt hängengeblieben bei einer Logitech G403.
Die Kabel-Variante.
Und auf der Arbeit habe ich
eine Ducky One Skyline Tastatur.
Und daheim habe ich eine Corsair Platinum K95.
Und die Software, ich sage es euch, die Software von dieser Tastatur,
ich zeige euch das mal,
ist dazu wirklich, da fallen dir die Haare von aus.
Allein schon das, was hat es denn jetzt schon für Probleme?
Was, was genau hat es für Schmerzen?
Profiles-Konflikt.
To resolve conflict,
click, yes.
Ne, click, yeah, save.
Okay, save.
Das war es jetzt, oder was?
Also die, guck mal, das ist auch schon übelst lahm, ne?
Du klickst hier drauf,
es braucht eine halbe Stunde, bis es geswitcht ist,
ganz, ganz schlimm.
Also diese, diese, diese Corsair-Software ist wirklich grausam.
Ganz, ganz, also wirklich, wirklich grausam.
Na, man kann jetzt natürlich irgendwie diese komische Lightning-Effekte anmachen,
die
irgendwie nicht an sind.
Doch, jetzt sind sie an.
Man kann,
was ich ganz, was ich ganz cool als Effekt finde, ist Puls, war es, glaube ich.
Ja, da pulst die Tastatur so vor sich hin.
Das ist eigentlich ganz nett.
Wobei es auch wieder verschenktes Potenzial ist, letztendlich.
Oh, das habe ich noch nie hochgedreht hier.
Oh, da drehst du ja, drehst du ja ab bei.
Kommst du dir, kommst du dir vor wie im Krankenwagen.
Ja, wobei auch schon ein bisschen hier die Chance verschenkt ist,
dass man hier beispielsweise, ähm,
sagen kann, ich will alle Farmen plus, ich will eine rauslassen.
Also die Corsair-Software ist wirklich scheiße.
Muss man echt sagen.
So, und Advanced gibt lustigerweise weniger Optionen.
Guck, das ist die Auswahl für, ähm,
für Advanced
und das ist die Auswahl für Basic.
Easy Advanced.
Ich habe, ich dachte eigentlich immer, Advanced ist Basic und mehr.
Aber bei Corsair ist das anders.
Die Tastatur ist halt richtig cool.
Also, Spielen ist, macht hier nichts.
Das macht hier mit wirklich Spaß.
Tippen geht halbwegs, aber, ähm, ich habe das Gefühl,
die Tasten sind einen Millimeter kleiner als bei anderen Tastaturen.
Das bringt mich oft aus dem Konzept.
Deswegen seht ihr mich in letzter Zeit auch mich oft,
oft so extrem verdrücken, wenn ich irgendwas schreiben will, ne?
Ihr erinnert euch ja noch hier dran, irgendwie, wenn ich,
wenn ich dann anfangen will.
Künzle, oder diese Konsole.
Ja, funktioniert nicht.
So, und das liegt an der Tastatur.
Ja, und auf der Arbeit habe ich mir extra hier noch eine geholt.
Und die ist zum, zum Schreiben und vom Gefühl her,
eigentlich viel nicer.
Nämlich die da.
Ich glaube, das ist aber eine 2 oder so, die ich habe.
Genau.
Die mit, äh, mit Nummernblock.
Ich brauche, ich bin NumBlock-Fan.
Ich mag NumBlocks.
Die haben auch, die hat auch so eine schöne Beschichtung oben auf den,
oder generell sind die Tasten bei der aus Plastik,
was sich ein bisschen rauer anfühlt.
Das macht insgesamt einen besseren Eindruck.
Und auf jeden Fall, was man mit beiden Tastaturen kann,
wenn der Einbrecher einen nachts überrascht
und man sitzt noch am Rechner,
dann kann man ihn mit der Tastatur easy-ownen.
Die Tastaturen sind wirklich schwer.
Also sie sind wirklich,
kannst du als Waffe einsetzen,
die sind gefährlich.
Beide, beide.
Ja.
Die hat unten auch ein bisschen ein Polster dran.
Und, äh, die Tasten sind halt bei der,
bei der hier zum Schreiben und zum Arbeiten richtig cool.
Und zum Spielen sind die Tasten hier schon ein bisschen mehr responsive.
Das merkt man.
Zumindest bilde ich mir das ein,
dass man das merkt.
Aber an sich macht es irgendwie einen billigeren Eindruck,
obwohl es teurer ist.
Komisch eigentlich.
Na ja.
Gut, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Genau, Kickstarter.
Haben wir jetzt schon sortiert, das Ganze.
So, wir haben sortiert nach Spielen.
Wir haben sortiert nach Hardware.
Okay.
Leute, seid ihr bereit für World First Performance Enhancing Game,
für den World First Performance Enhancing Game?
World First Performance Enhancing Gaming Glove.
Seid ihr bereit für den Handschuh,
der eure Performance, euer Aim,
eure KD,
eure 360 Nose Scopes und Quickscopes, äh, verbessert?
Ich mach mal kurz Musik aus.
Eigentlich brauchen wir keine Musik, weil wir Kickstarter haben.
Ach, gucken wir uns das Ganze mal an.
Ihr müsst mir gleich nochmal sagen, ob die Lautstärke okay ist.
Also, World First Performance Enhancing Gaming Glove.
Video?
Die Gaming Industry is growing bigger and bigger every day.
Ein bisschen lauter.
Millions of people are using a computer mouse for gaming
and encounter the discomfort of high friction against the mousepad
and the lack of stability while maneuvering the mouse.
Because of this, gamers around the world are performing worse
and suffer from injuries.
Moment, was? Moment, Moment.
Warte mal, das muss ich mir nochmal anhören.
The Gaming Industry is growing bigger and bigger every day.
Millions of people are using a computer mouse for gaming
and encounter the discomfort of high friction against the mousepad
and the lack of stability while maneuvering the mouse.
Because of this, gamers around the world are performing worse
and suffer from injuries.
Hallo, meine...
Ernsthaft?
Ich hatte noch nie, also, ich hatte noch nie Injuries dadurch,
dass ich mir die Hand am Mousepad aufgerieben hab, oder so.
I'm the founder and CEO of Flashy Gaming Group.
As a gamer at a high level, I always look for ways to improve my gameplay
and to prevent me from getting injured.
During the last two years, I've tried to find a solution
for the problems that gamers encounter every day while using a computer mouse.
Oh geil, es wird 3D gedruckt.
I'm so happy to finally present the world's first patent-pending,
performance-enhancing gaming glove.
The Flashy Gaming Glove...
Sieht aus wie eine Schiene, wenn man sich den Arm gebrochen hat, ein bisschen.
Aber die Idee ist...
...consist of four key components.
Gar nicht so blöd.
The gaming sleeve, the friction reduction, the angle improvement
and the rotation support.
Compression sleeves have been used for a long time in many sports,
for example basketball.
The reason for this is that studies show that compression sleeves
help with blood circulation, body temperature,
reduce muscle stress and faster recovery.
With all these benefits, we believe that our gaming sleeve
will be a key component to esports and the everyday gamer.
To me, it makes no sense that gamers are playing with a computer mouse
that has a low friction against the surface,
and yet their underarm and their wrist have a high friction.
With the Flashy Gaming Glove, you don't have to worry about this problem.
The underside is covered with Teflon,
the same friction-reducing material that you usually find
on the underarm of your mouse.
The inside of your mouse.
This means that you will finally be able to become one with your mouse
and move it easier than ever before.
Today's typical use of a computer mouse
does not provide you with a healthy angle for the wrist.
This leads to poor mouse movement and in turn injuries.
Flashy Gaming Glove has a built-in incline
that always provides you with an optimal angle towards the mouse.
Finally, I'm so happy to present the world's first rotation support for gaming.
Precision is extremely important while you are gaming,
and the rotation support provides you with a control movement for perfect precision.
And once again...
It looks like a thrombosis drop.
On top of that, you can get it in different sizes and four different colors.
Red, blue, green and white.
If you want the world's first performance-enhancing gaming glove
that is also beneficial for your health, then back us.
So we can get the production started
and hopefully make many more new and exciting products in the future.
Thank you so much for taking the time to watch this video.
I hope you enjoyed it.
I'll see you in the next video.
Bye!
Oh, da müsst ihr euch aber...
Guck mal, und das gibt's schon im Februar!
Das kann man backen und direkt gucken, was Sache ist.
Eigentlich...
Eigentlich gar nicht.
Ich glaube, das werde ich backen nachher.
Ich glaube, da gebe ich nachher meine Kohle für aus.
Haben wir nicht...
Haben wir nicht irgendwie mal ordentliche Hintergrundmusik?
Best Zelda Music Compilation.
So.
Nice.
Wir machen Zelda...
Dings, die...
Die 20...
20...
Die ist übelst nice.
Die ist mega nice.
Geht leider nur 45 Minuten.
Ach so, ich sollte vielleicht mal ein bisschen lauter machen, ne?
So.
Kirby-Musik!
Oh ja, Kirby-Musik endlich!
Ja, hatten wir schon so lange nicht mehr.
Gefühlt...
Gefühlt schon Monate nicht mehr.
Kirby, äh...
Gourmet Race, äh...
10 Stunden.
Bam.
Endlich wieder.
De...
So.
Das ist gut.
Das ist gute Hintergrundmusik.
Beste.
Weiß jemand zufällig, wie man am dümmsten Daten von einem iPhone auf ein OnePlus überträgt?
Also am dümmsten...
enhanced wie sie sich das hier wie sie das hier erzählen ich habe so meine zweifel dran aber von
der idee her ist das mal wenigstens was neues und nach den ganzen gaming utensil die wir uns
in letzter zeit so angeguckt haben zum beispiel gaming tische die komplett useless waren dann
dann doch lieber so was und man kriegt schon welche early bird sleeve hat sich die währung
hat sich umgestellt und hat sich die währung umgestellt moment alle hier 25 dollar gibt es
ein kommt man sind nur noch sechs stück übrig da müssen wir jetzt theoretisch kann ich das
nicht mal vielleicht in deutschland irgendwie also nach deutschland kostet wie viel 29 euro okay
ja kann man machen gut heißt next game attack customer ist your game professional controller
custom nah das wird uns nicht an das ist irgendwie was soll das überhaupt sein ach so man kann irgendwie
immer kann irgendwie das gleiche teil an an jetzt irgendwie einen game controller machen oder game
controller sein also warum warum
was mache ich damit wozu brauche ich das weiß nicht bonus tracking da ist okay das ist für
leute spiele also offline games spielen vielleicht nicht schlecht so verbraucht so game book mobile
playstation xbox laptop für everybody moment die können nicht einfach playstation xbox dinger
verkaufen es sei denn
das ding sieht ja mal mega hässlich aus und soll das bei optisch optik eigentlich fast egal wobei
dinge die tragen kannst ja du ino gameboy kann man eigentlich auch nicht nintendo switch pro controller
joystick fix was muss man am was muss man daran fixen weiß dass jemand hallo video high quality
high quality render ich sehe schon hier
hey kickstarter happy holidays
kickstarter project
körper aus
controller joysticks
so denn
ist das nicht so
ist das echt so
Ist das so?
Na gut.
Das war das, also der N64-Controller, der ist dick und das war wirklich crap, das Ding.
Die Musik?
Okay.
Das braucht doch kein Mensch, oder? Braucht man das?
Okay, das ist im Prinzip einfach ein Metallring.
Egal, weiter, next.
Arcana war nix für mich.
Oculus Rift.
Gibt's mal wieder was? Ah ne, Development Kit.
Danach kriegt glaube ich kein Hahn mehr, ey.
Ne?
Das ist schon wieder voll vorbei.
Oh, das musst du einem Kollegen schicken, weil ich weiß nicht, ob ich's mal im Stream erzählt hab,
aber ein Kollege von mir ist dabei, so eine Arcade-Gaminghalle zu bauen, so mit solchen Dingern hier.
Und das muss ich ihm mal zeigen, vielleicht ist das ja was für den.
Da muss ich dann irgendwann mal, wenn das Ding fertig ist, muss ich dann auch mal ein bisschen Promotion machen, aber das dauert noch.
So.
Ich glaube, Hardware-Projekte haben wir genug geguckt.
Da ist jetzt nichts sonderlich geiles dabei.
Der Gaming-Glove war natürlich wieder das Highlight jetzt hier.
Kleiner Favorit, dass ich mich nicht eingelacht hab.
Ich kann mich jetzt auch hier auch streamlich einloggen.
Okay, gucken wir mal Gaming-Projekte. Was gibt's denn hier?
96 Projekte?
Moment.
Warum nur 96 Projekte?
Ich hab irgend... Moment, ich hab irgendwas verkehrt sortiert.
Spiele.
Projekte in Spiele erkunden.
Das Kickstarter-Sortier-Funktion ist ganz, ganz merkwürdig.
Äh, Videospiele?
12.000 Projekte.
Okay.
Und witzigerweise, die Sucheinstellungen sehen genau gleich aus.
Sortiert nach, ähm...
Was ist denn da, was meint ihr jetzt am besten?
Beliebtheit sortieren oder Erscheinungsdatum?
Oder Datum bis Ablauf?
Machen wir mal Enddatum.
Oh nein, Graphic Novels wieder.
Please.
Mich schon wieder.
Das letzte Mal hat der halbe Stream aus irgendwelchen...
Aus irgendwelchen...
Eieiei.
Muss das sein.
Immer.
Immer der krasse Weepshit.
Sag mal, macht diese, macht diese Graphic Novel-Geschichte, macht das kein großer Hersteller?
Weil, das kann doch nicht sein, dass die Dinger so übertrieben beliebt sind.
Ich versteh immer noch nicht, warum das hier so unterschiedlich ist, die Kategorie.
Zulull.
Okay, dann gucken wir uns erst mal diese Seite an, weil die hat ja nur sechs Neunsch-Projekte.
Weshalb auch immer.
Okay, ähm, Team Favorite.
Ach, das sind, das sind quasi, äh, Recomment oder sowas, ne?
Weil das, weil das, äh, Team Favorite Games sind.
Oder auch nicht.
Okay, Leute.
Seid ihr bereit für den krassen Weepshit?
Enddatum.
Oh, ganze 480 Euro möchte er haben.
Pixel.
Wie?
Ja, gibt's überhaupt keine, gibt's überhaupt kein, kein Weepvideo zu.
Bei, bei dem hab ich live und beim anderen nicht.
Ja, was ist live überhaupt?
Live.
Was ist live?
A new way of bringing creative projects alive.
Live.
Moment, sind das Typen, die irgendwie streamen oder so?
Ach, das sind die Typen, die live streamen.
Das heißt, der Dude hier ist am live streamen.
Seh ich das richtig?
Oder auch nicht?
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Kickstarter.
Oh.
Ja, fängt man ganz an.
Okay.
Das müssen wir uns denn hier angucken.
Die haben kein Video.
Projekte ohne Videos, äh, find ich doof.
Das sieht mir aber nach, ähm, Graphic Novel aus.
So wie es hunderttausende Stück auf Kickstarter gibt.
So.
Winter Wanderer.
Science Fiction Travel Action RPG.
Die Videos kacken übelst ab, ne?
Die brauchen voll lang zum Laden.
Oh.
Schau mal.
Nice Grafik.
Aber ganz schön bauchfrei.
Das ist wichtig, dass man...
Hier ist man besonders gut gepanzert.
Was?
Was genau gucke ich mir da an?
Oh.
Band.
Monka Toss.
Haha.
Ich weiß ja nicht.
Na, ich weiß nicht.
Ähm.
Da...
Passiert da nochmal irgendwas?
Oh, das ist eher Puzzle.
Puzzle, Puzzle.
Oh, fuck.
Oh.
Oh, Fight.
Krasser Fight.
Bam.
Weggeslided.
OK.
Um, um was geht es denn eigentlich?
Was wollt ihr uns sagen?
Hi, I'm Kayce McCullough, gamedesigner here at Timeless Games.
Hi.
beginning to feel lost in the world that surrounds you, the feeling of wanting to advance in
the storyline, these feelings are what we're...
Ja.
.
Okay, um was geht's?
Es sah absolut nicht nach Zelda Classic Gameplay aus.
Absolut nicht.
2018er PlayStation Awards, Spanien nominiert.
Gut.
Wenn ich mir angucke, was für die komischen deutschen Gaming Awards da immer nominiert ist, dann heißt das erstmal gar nichts.
Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung, was das sein soll, außer dass es angeblich Zelda-Style ist.
Und, äh, ja, die anscheinend wohl auch schon mal ein Game gemacht haben.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Nicht meins.
Okay, nix.
Ruins to Rumble.
Das ist noch mehr Pixel.
Wisst ihr, 10 Pixel waren zu viel.
Wir sind bei einem Pixel angekommen.
Mein Sound ist nicht kaputt, das hat keinen Sound.
Ich werde, ich werde, was ist das denn?
Ich werde mal den passenden Sound kurz einblenden.
Was?
Was sehe ich da überhaupt?
Er kann Baumstämme aneinander bauen, oder Holzdinger aneinander, und dann schweben sie in der Luft.
Und das ist so Terraria Light, oder, oder?
What?
Pavilion Man, ja, das können wir machen am Ende des Jahres noch.
Das schreibe ich mir mal auf.
Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung, was in dem Game gehen soll, aber es sieht jetzt nicht so, nicht so, nicht so exciting aus, irgendwie.
Das sieht mega langweilig aus.
Was machen die da überhaupt?
Was geht's da?
Was?
Frederico, das ist der von Miracoli.
Okay.
Der hat einen Ausruf, er hat eine Quest, oder wie, oder was, oder warum?
Das ist absolut nichts, sagt er.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Ruhi zu arme.
Kolonisierung Survival Game.
About Base Building and Island Exploration.
Für 5,91 Euro.
Easy.
Also, wenn ihr, wenn ihr das backen wollt, da.
Okay, next.
Ähm, Tactic, äh, Tactics, äh, ach, das, das Game heißt Tactics, ich hab's, der Satz ist einfach.
Tactics, a turn-based, äh, Videogame for PC, Mac and Linux.
Ah.
Er möchte 32K haben.
Da gucken wir doch mal für was.
Kein Video.
Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen optimistisch.
Wisst ihr, ich will, Sound, oh, oh, es gibt, es gibt auch schon ein Battle Theme.
Oh-oh.
Oh!
Hauptsache Chor.
Das haben die sich doch garantiert, aus irgendwelchen Stockdingern zusammengemixt, oder?
100 Pro, haha.
Oder, es ist, oder, es ist von irgenso nem Studio gekauft.
Es gibt ja mittlerweile relativ viele Studios, die ähm, so, so Chalermusik und Gedäんな .....
basteln.
Okay, weiter gehts mit, po..
Ich habe S-Rocket-Pinguin gelesen.
Ähm, Pocket-Pinguin, Gameboy-Style-Adventure.
Hey Dude, down here is the download link to play the demo of Pocket-Penguin.
Having said that, I'm off. My people need me.
Oh, viel zu laut.
Die Musik gefällt mir.
Das ist stylisch.
Irgendwie gefällt mir das, wobei ich keine Gameboy-Spiele mag in der Regel.
Ah, die Musik geht ab.
Ich würde mir den Soundtrack kaufen, nicht das Spiel.
Okay, was man in dem Game genau macht, erschließt sich mir nicht so richtig.
Das ist auf der einen Seite ein bisschen so Jump'n'Run-mäßig.
Und dann irgendwie so Bomberman.
Weiß nicht.
Und zwischendurch habe ich Pinguin drauf.
Gut, alles klar.
Also, Sound hat mir gut gefallen.
Die Demo muss ich nicht spielen.
Ähm, ich glaube nicht, dass mir das Game vom Gameplay her gefällt.
Denn ich muss auch dazu sagen, ich bin eigentlich kein großer Fan von Gameboy-Spielen.
Ich hatte zwar einen Gameboy und ich habe auch relativ viel Gameboy damals gespielt.
Aber es war auf dem Gameboy bis, bis vielleicht bis auf Link's Awakening eigentlich nichts dabei, wo ich jetzt sagen würde, oh, da erinnere ich mich gern dran.
So, ich war kein großer Pokémon-Fan.
Das ist für mich schon mal rausgefallen.
Und, ähm.
Ähm, die anderen Sachen, die es da so gab.
Ich meine, das Mario auf dem Gameboy war übelster Crap.
Also das erste, das erste, ja.
Das zweite war dann auch schon ganz okay.
Hast du mittlerweile das Lied von Till Lindemann in Haftbefehl gehört?
Nein.
Noch nicht, aber das müssen wir nachher machen noch.
Ich habe es ja gestern versprochen, wir gucken uns das an.
Okay, weiter.
Ne, das hatten wir schon.
Okay, äh.
Snow Ash Land.
2D-Multiplayer-Top-Down-Shooter-Game.
Okay.
Schon 200 Euro.
Du hast eine Musik?
Wo du denkst, jetzt kommt gleich das übelst geile, was weiß ich, Raumschiff reingeflogen.
Irgendwas super geiles.
Und dann fährt dann irgendwie so ein 2D-Panzer rum.
Ne, das ist kein 2D-Panzer, das ist ein Typ.
So quasi Contra von oben.
Okay, mit Craft-Elementen.
Das braucht jedes Game heutzutage, Craft-Elemente.
Und Survival-Elemente natürlich auch, das geht nicht ohne.
Oh, diese Emission.
Äh.
Das sieht jetzt...
Ehrlich gesagt, ein bisschen langweilig aus.
Ich meine, es gibt ja auch 3 Milliarden Spiele dieser Art jetzt.
Das ist schon Resilience-Lieferung, das gefällt mir nicht.
Aber sie haben sich mit dem Trailer zumindest so weit Mühe gegeben.
Ja, das stimmt, das habe ich mir auch gerade gedacht.
Die Musik passt dazu.
Oh, hier wird gecraftet.
Und Wege.
Wege, es werden Wege gecraftet.
Nicht etwa Häuser, hier werden Wege gecraftet.
Hast du schon was zum Epic Store gesagt?
Ja, hab ich auch gesagt.
Nö.
Ich finde...
Muss ich mal kurz einladen.
Ich finde das gut, dass Steam da Konkurrenz kriegt.
Und sie geben ja auch mehr an die Entwickler ab, also.
Ich finde das nicht schlecht.
Okay.
Der Trailer haben sie sich Mühe mitgegeben.
Äh.
Rest.
Hm.
Nope.
Was haben wir als nächstes?
Crime.
Oh, Weep-Kram wieder.
Eine Visual Novel.
Wie...
So viele.
Da gibt es so viele.
Warum gibt es da so viele von?
Und warum boxt sie sich ins Gesicht?
Man weiß es nicht.
Ah, ja, ja.
Die...
Wir müssen uns eigentlich gar nicht den Trailer angucken.
Die sind alle gleich.
Die sind alle gleich gefühlt.
Nee.
Ich will mir nicht heute wieder einen ganzen Tag
Visual Novel Trailer angucken.
Caster Arena.
Next.
Oh, High Quality Pixel Art sieht man hier schon mal.
Der hat sich...
Der hat sich auch gedacht wie der Letzte.
Warum nicht mal ein Bild mit 10 Pixeln machen?
Wenn es...
Wenn die anderen 300 nehmen.
Was genau geht da ab?
Boah!
HD.
Moment.
Diesen Effekt...
Diesen Effekt, den müssen wir uns gerade noch mal angucken.
Achtung.
BAAAM!
Ich mein...
HD ist vielleicht jetzt auch ein bisschen...
...overrated?
Overrated?
So ein bisschen vielleicht, ne?
Ich meine, okay, hier konnte man
auch irgendwie sagen, okay, er
wollte einfach
möglichst minimalistisch das
machen. Dafür ist es okay.
Und hier muss man jetzt sagen,
das sieht kacke aus.
Es tut mir leid, aber irgendwie...
Ach ne, ich weiß nicht.
Nope.
Zum Gameplay kann ich
nichts sagen. Moment, was?
Er benutzt
Visual Studio Community Edition.
Da kann man schon mal sagen, er hat sich zumindest das Richtige ausgesucht
als Entwicklungsumgebung.
Arcade Con. Moment, das hatten wir das letzte Mal
schon. Das ist irgendwie so eine Messe, wo man
wo man, äh...
Wo schon 1 Euro gespendet wurde!
1 Dollar von 87!
Nice!
Die Leute scheinen da super scharf drauf zu sein, hinzugehen.
Das ist, das sieht aus wie
ein, das ist entweder Zombie Survival
oder, ähm, oder ein Ding.
Ist ein Battle Royale Game.
Sieht schon irgendwie so aus.
66 Euro
von 350.000!
Jetzt geht's aber ab hier.
Schauen wir mal.
The fuck?
Er hat ein paar Presets genommen und
in die, in die, äh, ähm...
Äh, nicht Presets, Prefabs genommen und...
Das war's?
Ha ha ha ha!
The fuck?
DTF?
But why?
Okay!
66 Dollar sind schon gebacked.
Oh man, das ist, das ist ein deutscher Entwickler, oder?
Das ist ein, das ist ein deutscher,
deutscher Text.
Für, okay.
Äh, soll ein Survival Crafting
Dinosaurier Jagd Game für den...
Boah, das ist aber alles, das hat alles.
Jetzt fehlt eigentlich noch Battle Royale.
Survival Crafting Dinosaurier Battle Royale Jagd Game
für den PC werden, welches die
Möglichkeiten bietet, welches
für, Moment, was ist das denn?
Für den PC werden, welches die Möglichkeit bieten,
soll, Strukturen auf der Insel zu bauen.
Und das Jagen nach Dinosaurier.
Stegosaurus vs.
Uterraptor.
Hm.
Ja, wir haben uns quasi den...
Was ist denn das? Ne, das ist, das ist Unreal.
Wir haben uns den Unreal Editor genommen
und ein paar Demo-Dinger drauf
gebaut und uns nen
Dinosaurier-Model gekauft.
Easy Clap!
Death by Bacon.
Es wird, es wird immer hochkarätiger
klar, gerade.
Immer hochkarätiger heute.
8K für Death by Bacon.
Okay, es ist zumindest nicht RPG Maker.
Das ist schon mal nicht schlecht.
Okay, was haben wir hier zu bieten?
A Comedy-Metrovania-Game.
Im Weep-Style.
Jawohl, kein Video.
Doch!
Oh, der Rock, der wippt aber ganz schön.
Die Sounds.
Alter, die Sounds.
Das Video hängt nicht, das Game hängt.
Was genau gucken wir uns da gerade an?
Okay, kommt er?
Okay, kommt da noch was?
Moment, wir gucken uns jetzt mal
die YouTube-Bewertung an, was die Leute da so zu schreiben.
Oh, die finden das alle klasse.
Okay, gut.
Naja.
Ich mein,
es sieht zumindest optisch besser aus
als die Games vorher.
Was absolut keine Kunst ist, wenn man sich das hier
so zum Beispiel anguckt.
Next.
Burst Soccer. Was?
Burst the Mets Soccer.
Realistisches Fußballspiel.
Okay.
Kein Video.
Nichts.
Sehr fein.
Resident Evil
like game.
Okay.
Da muss man gucken.
What?
Probabilmente faro la loro stessa fine.
Passo e chiudo.
Okay, ragazzi.
Siete pronti per quest'Operazione?
Okay, die Italiener sind am Start.
Sind sie? Das sind Italiener, oder?
Soldati, stiamo precipitando.
Was?
Was geht ab?
Wie, das ist ein Trailer?
Oh, jetzt kommt noch was.
Devo riuschire a scappare da quest'Inferno.
Brando, Mattia, mi ricevete.
Merda.
Die, aber was ich geil finde,
die reden voll überzeugt.
Hört euch das mal an, so.
Riuschire a scappare da quest'Inferno.
Brando, Mattia, mi ricevete.
So voll überzeugt, ey.
Ich mein, es sieht zumindest optisch nicht ganz so schlimm aus
wie der Rest vorher.
Die Laufanimation ist schon absolut,
die ist Weltklasse, die Laufanimation.
Oh, no.
Sergente.
Morite, basta.
Guardi.
Fuck.
Aber, man muss jetzt mal dazu sagen,
das ist ja,
hätte man sowas vor ein paar Jahren gezeigt,
würde man sagen,
zumindest technisch haben sie was drauf,
das kann man heute aber gar nicht mehr so sagen,
weil du nimmst dir irgendwie den Unity oder einen Unreal
lädst du dir runter
und das Game sieht halt, wenn man halbwegs
kompetent ein bisschen ein ordentliches Level baut,
das sieht halt gut aus.
Dann kaufst du dir aus dem Shop noch ein paar
Models und dann sieht das halt einfach ganz gut aus.
In so einem guten Game macht's
das natürlich noch lange nicht.
Okay, die wollen einfach mal 100k.
Easy. Clap. 100k. Kein Ding.
Okay, weiter geht's.
Echoes VR.
Oh, die sind schon
ziemlich, ziemlich weit gebackt.
Wow.
You've heard about it, haven't you?
The story of Saddler.
No rumors like everyone.
The expedition S32
disappeared, just leaving
confusing transmission.
Saddler is the key.
Saddler,
the source of life.
Looks like we're where they got lost.
But what happened to them?
And what is Saddler?
No one knows.
Get to their camp, maybe then we will find out.
Okay, man sieht an der rumgewackelt schon,
das ist ein VR-Game.
Moin, Ancient
Distria?
Das stimmt.
What am I looking at?
What is this place?
These caves are puzzling.
I'm sure the vegetal species
and creatures you are registering
have never been seen before.
We have to study them.
Das Interface erinnert mich ein bisschen an Dead Space.
Findet ihr nicht auch?
Sarah, this is the place the expedition
said come here.
Es ist abenteuerlich.
Was haben sie entdeckt?
Es soll einen erschrecken.
Okay, passiert jetzt noch was?
Er stellt sich einen ab.
Das war's für den Fabian das Spiel.
Man muss man schleichen,
man mag Spiele, wo man schleichen muss.
Kack Aiming System wie in jedem VR-Spiel,
aber du kannst es ja auch irgendwie nicht
bescheid machen.
Das könnte nicht schlecht sein.
Zu wenig gute VR-Games.
Wenn das ein gutes VR-Game ist, dann her damit.
Auch wenn ich kein VR-Zeug hab.
So.
Ähm.
Ist im Chat.
SuperPiglet.
Äh, kein Video. Und Tschüss.
Feinsts...
Was? Feinsts...
Undead Coop Killing.
Ich ahne Schlimmes.
Hallo, Video?
Ah.
Mehr übersteuern, bitte.
Oh, das Interface.
Easy.
Also.
Nein.
Come on, bruh.
Muss das wirklich...
Es ist 2019.
Fast.
Mit einer Zeit voraus.
Was halt witzig ist, ne?
Das ist voll das krasse Coop-Game.
Komm, Coop.
Oh, doch. Jetzt.
Jetzt. Coop.
Intensifies.
Äh.
Ja. Gut.
Next.
Okay.
Typing faster.
Okay. Zeig mal her.
Warum laden die Videos heute so lang?
Das ist ein...
Typing-Game?
Ja, gut.
Warum nicht?
Flappy Bird.
Nee.
Okay, ist das ein Spiel, wo man schreiben lernt?
Oder sowas in der Richtung?
Ja, ich glaub, das ist ein Game, wo man schreiben lernt.
Also.
Da fällt mir jetzt nichts in dieser Kategorie ein.
Das heißt, wenn es gut gemacht ist, warum nicht?
Weil ich meine Zweifel habe,
dass es halt wirklich motiviert hat,
zu schreiben zu lernen. Also schnell schreiben.
Oder vielleicht auch blind schreiben oder so.
Marv meint, dass es für Kinder gut kann.
Ich mein,
mir fällt kein anderes Spiel dieser Art ein.
Außer ein paar Browser-Games.
Ähm. Warum nicht?
Ha. Bam.
Wenn ihr den pädagogischen
Wert darin erkannt habt,
dann könnt ihr ja backen.
Wir gucken uns jetzt, wir gucken uns jetzt noch mal kurz das Gameplay an.
Ich mein,
zumindest haben sie mal einen Typ, der, äh,
Grafiken machen kann. Ja, also das sieht,
das sieht nicht so fürchten aus, wie der Rest, den wir vorher geguckt haben.
Das sieht schon mal ganz nice aus.
Für das, was es sein soll.
Ja, es ist wirklich.
Na gut. Ähm.
Sagen wir mal so, WHSD kriegt prinzipiell
eigentlich jeder Gamer hin.
Oh, das kriegt, das ist easy für die Wim-Leute. Easy.
Kein Problem.
Es starrt einem direkt in die Seele.
Ja.
Okay, das ist genau so was, was wir gedacht haben.
Ein Spiel, wo man Typen spiel, äh, wo man
Typen spielt.
Wo man Tippen übt.
Wobei das hier jetzt noch ziemlich easy aussieht.
Easy.
Okay, so spannend ist es jetzt auch nicht.
Wie gesagt, ich hab's euch in die, ähm,
in den Chat, äh, gepostet.
Ich hab's in den Chat rein-eliminiert, wie man so
schon sagt.
So, jetzt haben wir als nächstes Bavaria.
Nein.
Bayani Fighting Game.
Nicht Bavaria. Ähm.
Demo available.
Oh, nice.
Okay, das ist ein Fighting Game.
Einmal ein hübsches Fighting Game.
Also ich find das vom Styler nicht ganz, ganz, ganz
gut.
Steckt bestimmt ein bisschen Arbeit drin.
Oh.
Mit richtigem Soundtrack.
Die Frage ist, ob das wirklich
ob das Soundtrack
von dem Game ist, oder ob der nicht einfach irgendein Soundtrack
runtergelegt hat.
Wahrscheinlich eher das, hä?
Okay, sie fighten sich halt einen ab.
War ein Fighting Game.
Hallo? Player?
Oh, ey.
Es ist ein Weep-Fighting-Game.
Ich will
eigentlich vorspulen, aber das mag der Browser
will nicht. Gut, dann nicht.
Kaninokakakupi.
Ah, ja.
Okay, 12k wollen sie.
Die Hälfte ist schon fast gebackt.
Was gefällt?
Help, Localize, oder...
Oh, Visual Novel. Blitzt nicht schon wieder.
Überall Visual Novels.
Oh.
Oh, Mann.
Immer der Kram. Immer der gleiche Kram, ey.
Immer
der gleiche Kram.
Warum gibt's
davon so viele auf Kickstarter?
Warum gibt's davon
so viele auf Kickstarter? Ich verstehe das einfach
nicht. The fuck?
Jetzt ohne was drüber, über die Qualität
zu sagen, aber warum gibt es so viele Visual Novels
auf Kickstarter?
Es ist ja fast jedes dritte Game.
So, was kommt als nächstes?
Oh.
Backlit 3015.
Oh, das sieht ja schon mal richtig eindrucksvoll aus.
Gibt nix zu. Gut.
Full Metal Plastik.
Es sieht
schlechter aus als Minecraft
und es hat Panzer.
Judith, jawoll!
Jawoll, so fängt meine Demo an.
Das hat übrigens
keinen Sound, ne? Ist nicht kaputt oder so.
Press any key. Ja, schön.
Oh, Moment.
Wir müssen den Text lesen
da unten.
Aha. Das ist seine Doktorarbeit
oder sowas in der Richtung.
Nein, nicht wirklich seine Doktorarbeit, seine Abschlussarbeit.
Das ist ne Abschlu...
Okay.
Ich weiß ja nicht. Wisst ihr, wenn
er das komplett selbst gemacht hätte, dann würde ich sagen
Respekt so, aber es ist ein Unity
Game. Das heißt, es ist nicht schwer
sowas zu machen.
Er hat's ja auch geschrieben hat's aus dem Asset Store.
The fuck? Und es ruckelt wie
Sau. Und er spielt das Game in
der Unity Umgebung. Warum?
Warum? Warum? Ach Gott.
Ah.
Ne. Der Zirkus Manager.
Barionics
Studio.
Hoffentlich hat das jetzt wieder Sound.
Zirkus
Manager. Erstmal nen LKW bauen.
Das weiß ich mir unter nem Zirkus
vorstellen. Als erstes mal nen LKW
bauen.
Das ist das Essentielle zu nem Zirkus, dass man erstmal
nen LKW macht.
Ja geht das jetzt aber mit Zirkus
Manager los?
Nein, jetzt wird ein neuer LKW
gemalt.
Was? Warum malt der uns LKWs
vor? Das Ding heißt
Zirkus Manager.
ETF?
Kein Zelt? Keine...
Nix. Ne LKW. Ah, das ist ne LKW,
wo du irgendwie Löwen oder so
einsperren kannst.
Ich weiß halt nicht, ob das...
So, was ich mir so unter Zirkus Manager
vorstelle ist...
Photoshop kann er. Ja, das stimmt. Das stimmt.
Grafik kann er. Wenn ich mir das hier anguck.
Was man da unten
gesehen hat, falls es von ihm ist.
Aber was genau hat das jetzt mit nem
Zirkus Manager Game zu tun?
Pavilion Man, das stimmt.
Wenigstens macht er es selbst. Das ist
richtig. Das kann man von den meisten Games
auf Kickstarter nicht sagen.
Die haben sich Unreal oder
Unity runtergeladen, per Assets rein,
ein paar Prefabs geschrieben, fertig.
Oh, jetzt will er es wissen.
Jetzt will er es wissen.
Also ich finde, die Ähnlichkeit ist verblüffend,
oder? Oder eher die?
Zirkus Manager.
Nice. Also
alles was wir gesehen haben in dem
Trailer hat mit einem Zirkus
Manager nicht allzu viel
zu tun, aber zumindest macht er seine Sachen selbst.
Was ich schon mal gut finde, deswegen
wenn ihr daran glaubt, Link.
Surviving Lan Bridge.
Lan Alter.
Eine Bodentextur.
Eine Kiste.
Aha.
Sowas gibt's nicht oft.
Okay.
Das kann gut sein.
Wenn das gut gemacht ist.
Ich mein, das sieht ein bisschen eher so aus wie
GTA San Andreas
oder so von der Grafik.
Aber.
Oh. Oh ja genau, so sieht's aus
wenn man im Baum fällt.
Ähm, okay.
Häuser sehen auch alle ziemlich gleich aus.
Okay, Leute.
Ich glaube kaum, dass man
so die Häuser gebaut hat in dieser Zeit, oder?
Ich mein, hier ist ein Haus.
Hier oben ist ein Dach und hier ist ein Fenster
und so. Und er guckt jetzt quasi in den
Dachboden vom anderen rein und kann da rüberklettern
oder was.
Was ist da los? Warum fallen die um?
Ah, weil Seuche.
Er bräuchte den, den, den...
Wie hieß das Ding, was wir letztens auf Amazon gesehen haben?
Den...
Den Pest Rejector bräuchte der.
Irgendwie den Pest Rejector von Amazon.
Das rejectet
die Pest, dann passiert nichts mehr.
Das Ding hieß wirklich Pest Rejector.
Manage Farms...
Okay, das ist...
Ja, das kann auch was werden, wobei man
nicht viel bisher von
sieht. Ähm...
Odyssey
of Gionna
num. Kein Video.
Freya and
the False Prophecy.
Nordische Mythologie. Das könnte ja was...
Das könnte ja was für mich sein.
Oh, da. Ganz viel Blut.
Muss man untermauern
jetzt. Oh, die
Sprungsounds!
Ha! Ha!
Huh! Huh!
Wow! Die Sounds!
Da merkt man, dass
da Leute dahinter sitzen, die schon mal ein Spiel gemacht
haben und auch schon mal einen Trailer produziert haben.
Da sieht wenigstens noch was aus.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das Game mich ansprechen
wird, aber zumindest sieht das
nicht so
wie so ein 0815 hingerostetes
Billig-Game aus.
Aber die Sprungsounds waren schon hart, oder?
Ha! Ha! Ho! Ho!
Das haben sie
irgendwo...
Weiß nicht. Weiß nicht, ob sie das live
recorded haben.
Beim passenden Anlass.
Ähm...
Okay, next.
Disabled Gamers.
Was?
Moment. Das ist kein Game, oder?
Das ist
ein Kanal für
ähm...
Wie heißt das?
Wenn ich jetzt sage, zurückgeblieben ist
instant der Bann raus.
Was heißt denn das?
Wie nennt man das jetzt politisch korrekt heutzutage?
Ähm...
Ja...
Sprich, die eine Behinderung haben,
dass man Entwicklungsstörungen
sowas wie, ähm...
Ich glaub so irgendwas wie Entwicklungsstörungen
oder sowas. Ähm...
Also quasi halb YouTube Deutschland
brauchen wir doch gar keinen eigenen Channel für.
Da gibt's doch genug
zumindest in Deutschland für.
Du hast das Gefühl, dass so ziemlich die Hälfte
der deutschen YouTube Channels irgendwie
zurückgeblieben ist.
Ja, das war jetzt gemein, aber...
Es ist so.
Keine Ahnung.
Es hat jetzt aber in der Gamer-Kategorie eigentlich nichts zu suchen.
The Spirit of Christmas.
Ein Runner-Game, oder?
Ist das irgend so ein Mobile-Kack?
Ah, gibt's gar nicht.
Zulull.
Da ist er wieder.
Anonymous. The Game.
Soon available.
Das sieht nicht so aus, als ist das soon available.
Grüner Code.
So muss das sein.
Moment.
Was haben wir da im Hintergrund?
Das ist garantiert
nicht der Code von seinem Game.
Das sieht mir aus,
wie irgendwo einfach
rauskopiert.
Das ist irgendwie...
Was weiß ich? Linux Kernel C-Code
oder irgendwie sowas.
Immerhin ist das echt der Code. Weiß man da noch nicht mal.
Ähm, was auch immer.
Keine Ahnung.
World War Blood of Our Fathers.
Historik...
Au, au, historisch. Genau.
Sind sie. Also das ist das,
was Battlefield nicht auf die Reihe gekriegt hat.
Da fuck.
Alter, die wollen's aber wissen.
Elf Millionen.
Das ist... Die wollen wirklich das nächste
Battlefield machen. Ich hab so meine Zweifel,
ob das was wird.
Elf Millionen.
Das ist schon sehr ambitioniert.
Wir haben keinen Trailer.
Elf Millionen.
Okay.
Zwölf Millionen eigentlich.
Ähm.
Kein Trailer?
Keine, keine
Konzept-Bilder?
Nix.
Voraussichtliche Lieferungen 2020.
Timeline.
Okay, wie sieht's aus?
Funding Rates bis...
Easy. Ihr habt natürlich
kein Problem. Bis Januar 2019
habt ihr zwölf Millionen. Überhaupt kein Ding.
Easy. Easy.
Also, easiest zwölf Millionen
of my life hier. Das ist...
Das ist überhaupt kein Ding. Easy.
Okay, wie geht's weiter? Im Februar
das Core-Team steht. Aha.
Marketing-Material im Februar...
März. Development-Material.
Also, sie haben's richt...
Sie haben's richt... Also, ich glaube, man
muss kein Hellseher sein,
wenn man da sagt, ich glaube, das wird nix.
Was haben wir als nächstes?
Die Venia Episode 1.
Acht Euro.
Oh, Kick-Ass-Lauf-Animation.
Die Lauf-Animation hat's in sich.
Schnippel-Sounds.
Fuck.
Der ist einfach gerade aufgeploppt.
Okay.
Das sieht... Das sieht echt...
Ich weiß nicht. Das sieht irgendwie
merkwürdig aus.
Die Lauf-Animation ist die beste, ja.
Optisch sieht's ein bisschen aus wie vom
Gamecube. Na, ich weiß nicht.
Wow.
Okay, kommt
da noch was? Sieben Minuten, das kommt mir nicht alles an.
Die Videos von Kickstarter sind heute
ein bisschen langsam. Sag mal, hat die keinen Fuß?
Nee, die hat den Fuß nur in dem...
T-Pose, jawoll. Beste.
Das hat mir jetzt noch gefehlt.
Gut.
Nee.
Warum ist das denn ein bisschen Team-Favorite,
was zum Teil... Was ist eigentlich Team-Favorite?
Team-Favorite.
Inspire T. Ah ja.
Ähm. Final...
What?
Detonation. Das hatten wir doch das letzte
Mal schon.
Der hat das einfach nochmal neu gelauncht,
oder? Man erkennt nix.
Das haben wir... Das hatten wir das letzte
Mal schon. Das hat das letzte Mal
schon nicht funktioniert.
Genau, das hatten wir das letzte Mal schon.
Und ich hab mir gedacht, was zum Teufel soll
das sein? Genau, das haben wir das letzte Mal
schon angeguckt, dieses komische...
Ding.
Origin of Infestation.
Echtzeitstrategie und
Oldschool-RPG in einem.
Will 60k haben.
Und das ist sehr early.
Das ist untexturiert early.
Das ist sehr untexturiert early.
Es war wahrscheinlich...
Es war wahrscheinlich zu viel verlangt für einen
Kickstarter-Trailer, mal hier ein paar rudimentäre
Trickstulen drüber zu klatschen, ne?
Oh. Oh, Mega-Physik-Engine.
Habt ihr das gesehen? Beste.
Wie in echt?
Was wollt ihr uns überhaupt zeigen mit dieser
Aktion jetzt? Man kann ein
Brett hinlegen, es fällt nicht runter und dann kann man drüber
laufen. Nice.
Garantiert irgendwelche
gekauften Models.
Ja. Das Ding sieht auch schon irgendwie...
Ach, ich weiß nicht. Die Dinge, die ich hier
gesehen habe, es wird immer schlimmer heute.
Oh, sie haben sowas wie Concept-Art.
Da ist bloß die Frage, ist das
ihres?
Weiß man ja nicht, ne?
Okay, next.
Einen Kurs?
Einen Kurs,
wie man den Unity-Asset-Store benutzt?
Oder was soll das?
Irgendeine Anleitung.
Travel.
Thank you for traveling.
Gibt keine...
Oh, das ist rein text-based. Oh, nee.
Dafür bin ich, dafür ist es mir
zu seit 2019 schon.
Royal Storm Bowling.
Wow, ein Bowling-Game. Ja, haben wir
lange drauf gewartet.
Irgendwie sehen viele von den Projekten
einfach nur aus wie Betrug.
Naja, also, man muss ja sagen,
bei den meisten Projekten sieht man ja schon irgendwo,
worauf man sich einlässt, wenn man nicht ganz,
ganz blind ist.
Und das heißt, man kann ja kaum von Betrug sprechen.
Die meisten Games sehen schon so aus, als wird's
nix. Wo man richtig
gemast wird, zum Beispiel, ist bei einer Hose.
Ja, hab ich euch ja schon erzählt.
300 Euro.
RIP.
Skamast wurde ich, aber richtig.
Was mich aber nicht davon abhält.
Kickstarter.
Oh, episches.
Episches Bowling-Spiel.
Bowling mit
Helikopter.
Was?
Was genau hab ich da jetzt gesehen?
Wartet mal. Moment.
Es ist ein Ball?
Ein Helikopter?
Noch mehr Ball? Blaulicht?
Kegel?
Äh.
Pff.
Alter, wer denkt so was aus?
Okay, 0% finanziert nach 13 Tagen.
Ich vermute mal, die 400 Euro
werden auch nix werden.
Der Markt für
Battle Royale Bowling-Spiele
ist, glaube ich, nicht
vorhanden.
Bowling-Spiele.
I'm not a monster, first contact.
Okay, das sieht zumindest so aus, als hat da jemand
drangesetzt, der ein bisschen artistisch
begabt ist.
Der will 260k.
Sechs Minuten, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht komplett an.
Skippen wir mal ein bisschen.
Er erinnert mich so ein bisschen an Fallout.
Oder Bioshock.
Bioshock.
Von der Ansage her.
Ach, das ist so ein bisschen
wie
dieses Söldner-Game, was es
früher gegeben hat.
So turn-based.
Also, jetzt haben sie zumindest
ordentlich gemacht in der Hintergrunde.
Was ist denn heute mit den Kickstarter-Videos los?
Guck dir das mal an.
Es buffert sich immer einen ab.
Das könnte auch an der Telekom liegen.
Selmore, ich wurde auch
skammast.
Ich bin auch nicht
derjenige, der das macht.
Ich bin auch nicht derjenige, der das macht.
Doch, ich wurde auch schammast.
Ich meine,
so ein rundenbasierter
Taktik-Stelldetal, warum nicht?
Es ist ja nicht so,
dass es als Gutes so viele gibt.
Und sie haben...
Sie sind ein normales Studio.
Keine Skammast-Aktion.
Sie haben Leute, die, sie haben Künstler, sie haben Programmierer und so.
Das ist schon mal, das steht zumindest schon mal auf ganz guten, hat schon mal gute Voraussetzungen.
Link, wenn euch das zusagt.
Was haben wir als nächstes?
A Miscreation.
Plattformer with Evolution.
4.300 Euro.
Wow.
Boah, die Musik macht ja nervös.
Wobei die eigentlich ganz nice ist.
Das hat ein bisschen was so Kirby-mäßiges.
Aber, okay, es wird plattformt, wie man das so kennt.
Und irgendwelche, was genau sind das für Dinger?
Hallo, ich wollte da hin zurück.
Was, was genau soll das sein?
Maiskolben.
Bestimmt Maiskolben.
Die irgendwas rausspritzen.
Warum fliegt es ein?
Ein Yoshi-Ei.
Es läuft.
Vorher hat es noch gekrabbelt.
Okay, es evo-luscht.
Es levo-luscht nicht, es evo-luscht.
Ähm, Link.
Könnte, ja, denke ich auch, es könnte durchaus was sein.
Requiem.
Was?
Ride of Tracks.
Schau mal hier mit schöner, das, ich finde, das sieht irgendwie so aus, als hat der Typ irgendwo Requiem als Schrift gekriegt und hat dann quasi nochmal auf das Bild was drunter geschrieben.
Und auch das hier.
Und dann irgendwie so seine Hand reingemacht oder so.
Achso, ist, ne Moment, es ist, es ist ein Augmented Reality Game, ja, okay, dann ist es ja, dann ist es ja, das kennen wir doch.
Das hat, das gab's doch das letzte Mal auch schon.
Und das kann nicht das gleiche gewesen sein, weil das letzte Mal, wo wir geschaut haben, das war, äh, 4. November oder so, das ist schon ne ganze Weile her.
Das kennen wir schon.
Ich glaub, die haben das einfach nochmal reingestellt.
Ja.
Genau, das war das Game, die einfach...
Die einfach random irgendwelche anderen Games als Trailer reingepackt haben.
Disney's Cars 3.
WTF?
Genau, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Die haben einfach irgendwelche Trailer von irgendwelchen anderen Games reingepackt.
Disney's Cars 3.
Weil das auch so viel mit Requiem
Ride of Dragons zu tun hat.
Okay, weiter geht's.
At Sea.
Horror Game. Oh.
Wie lange machst du heute noch?
Weiß nicht.
Voice Acting Top Notch.
Das ist schlechtes Voice Acting.
Cringe Voice Acting.
Du, der Rest sieht okay aus.
Das Voice Acting war aber,
wirklich, das war der größte Horror überhaupt.
Also das, ich finde
so das Ingame Zeug
für Leute, die Horror Games machen, sah das gar nicht so
schlecht aus.
Aber das Voice Acting,
das ist wirklich der Horror,
stell ich dir hin.
So, was haben wir als nächstes?
Super Realistic Autocross.
Ich ahne ja schon Schlimmes.
Ich habe übrigens, muss ich gerade mal erzählen,
ich habe heute ein bisschen weiter gebastelt
an das, was wir gestern
programmiert haben,
die Gegensprechanlage.
Ich habe da jetzt eine Web-Anwendung daraus gebastelt,
die schon halbwegs auf dem iPhone funktioniert
und auf dem Android-Tablet und sowas.
Kann ich euch die Tage mal zeigen.
Haben wir 1998?
Was das für...
Moment.
Für was für Plattformen
kommt das?
On Steam und Nintendo Switch.
Okay. Ja.
Okay.
Live.
Live. Wir können dem Entwickler live
zugucken beim...
Okay, jetzt müssen wir uns erstmal den Vikings Trailer angucken.
Wie sage ich die neue Vikings Staffel?
Ich habe schon vor einer Weile aufgehört
zu gucken.
Ich habe irgendwie bis Staffel 3
geguckt.
Was ist das?
Das sieht aus wie das billigste Rennspiel
aller Zeiten.
Vielleicht tue ich den aber auch vollkommen
unrecht jetzt und das ist mega geil.
Ist okay, aber sehr viel gelabert,
dass es vorangeht.
Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich Game of Thrones
nicht gut fand.
Ich habe die ersten zwei Staffeln geguckt.
Da ging es, finde ich.
Da war das dann auch ganz nice.
Aber danach hat sich das so krass im Kreis gedreht.
Immer.
Und so ohne Konsequenzen letztendlich irgendwie.
So ganz viel Intrigen
hier, Intrigen da und dann wird es
zackig aufgelöst und nichts ist passiert.
Vielleicht kratzt es irgendwie einer ab.
Game of Thrones, finde ich, ist mit so die
overratedste Serie überhaupt.
Okay. Adam's
Ascending.
One word.
What does Adam's Ascending mean to you?
Perfekt.
Oh.
Was geht mit den Kickstarter-Videos
heute ab? Die laden überhaupt nicht richtig.
You must find Adam's true purpose
by deciding on the path you want for yourself.
One path will have you mastering
the external abilities to accumulate
items or weapons. Warum genau liegt
jetzt auf dem Planet irgendwie eine AK-47 rum?
Hat da irgendwie einer mal eine logische
Erklärung für?
It's simple. The path to your purpose will be one that's tangible
the choice is yours.
But on top of that
we want you, the player...
Also die Kickstarter-Videos sind heute richtig
im Arsch. So nicht normal.
Okay, gucken wir uns hier nochmal
Pre-Alpha-Gameplay an. Vielleicht geht
YouTube besser. Ja, YouTube läuft
gut. Ein Lauf-Simulator.
Weltraum-Stelz
rumlaufen.
Auch wieder so ein Game. Super für den
Friseur geeignet. Jetzt fehlt bloß noch
Stelz-Elemente.
Die...
Die Game-Verhältnisse sind ein bisschen
merkwürdig so von...
Okay, aber es sieht zumindest schon mal aus,
als haben die sich irgendwas beigedacht.
Das kann man ja zu den meisten Games nicht sagen.
Also wer das backen möchte...
Link.
Die haben schon... Ja, die brauchen noch ein bisschen was.
Dass das was wird. 16 Tage verbleibend.
Also haben sie noch ein bisschen Zeit
bis nächstes Jahr.
Der Boss is back schreibt
Ich verstehe nicht, warum in Game of Thrones
so viele Fix-Szenen drin sind.
Die braucht kein Mensch.
Ja, das war ja die ersten paar...
Also die ersten zwei Staffeln war es natürlich auch schon, aber
da hat es zumindest oftmals noch
irgendwie so einen Story-Zweck
gehabt, ja.
Aber danach war es einfach nur, weil sie gemerkt haben,
dass das halt Marketing
technisch nicht
verkehrt ist, wenn die Leute da drüber labern.
Goblin Slayer Game.
Moment. Moment.
Ist Goblin Slayer nicht dieser
Goblin Rape
Games?
Das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Ist das nicht
dieser komische Anime, wo
die Goblins dann
irgendwie die Heilerin
vergewaltigen oder so?
Frag mich nicht, woher ich das weiß, aber...
Ähm... Nope.
Bee Crib.
Weeps. Ja.
Achso, das ist nur nachgemacht.
Ah ja. Dann ist es natürlich...
What kind of game will it be?
Okay, komm Leute.
Wir müssen...
Wir müssen unseren inneren Weep channeln, quasi.
Moment.
Das ist...
Das ist aber...
Das ist gerippt aus dem Anime.
Das ist... Moment.
Das ist kein offizielles Game von denen.
This wants to be a game.
Ach, die haben doch gar nicht die
Lizenz dafür. Verstehe.
Oh, scheiße.
Das gucken wir uns nicht an.
Okay, die...
Die haben ja einfach die...
Was zum Teufel?
Leute, Kickstarter, ey.
Bee Crib.
Best suit for playing hard.
Was?
Oh, ein neuer Stick.
Oh, wenn man das paart mit dem Gaming Glove,
den wir am Anfang hatten,
dann ist...
Dann ist aus. Dann ist das Skill real.
Oh nein! Der Controller ist kaputt.
Weltuntergang.
Und jetzt macht sie ihn wieder ganz.
Magic.
Was?
Ich...
Ich bräuchte für sowas echt ne Webcam, ja?
Ich bräuchte für sowas echt ne Webcam,
weil man manchmal gar nicht...
gar nicht gut rüberbringen kann,
irgendwie, wie man sich grade fühlt,
sondern einfach...
weil man einfach doof in die Kamera gucken kann.
Ähm...
Und was? 120.000?
What the fuck?
120.000?
Und ich weiß nicht, wozu man's braucht. Ähm...
Okay.
Äh, das ist irgendein Mobile Game, oder?
Das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Oder doch?
Das hat... wurde... wurde gebackt.
Max fails through E-Link.
Nee, ich weiß nicht.
Es wäre... es wäre für Streams
deutlich praktischer,
für sowas hier das mit Webcam machen zu können.
Das auf jeden Fall.
Hello, Kickstarter Community.
Hey.
Public announcement of our newest game
right here on Kickstarter.
Rainmaker 2.
Rainmaker 2 is a match 3 tower defense
city building and strategy game.
Rainmaker 2...
Was haben sie alles gemischt?
...
Match 3?
Was? Ein was?
...
Rainmaker 2 is a match 3...
Match 3?
City building and strategy game.
City building and strategy.
Rainmaker 2 will put your reflexes, cleverness,
pattern recognition and strategy to the test
and once you feel you've mastered the game,
you can go online to join with
or compete against other tower lords.
competitive tower defense.
that opened 22 years ago in 1996.
Our first game,
a text-based, online RPG
called threshold,
is still in operation.
This will be our fourth game on Kickstarter
and all things are so awesome
Ich meine, der Typ kann zumindest sein Game schon mal gut anpreisen, ja?
Die Mechanics sind stellar.
Das ist so ein Spruch, den hätte auch irgendein Typ von EA auf der Bühne loslassen können, ja?
Pavilion Man gibt es bestimmt, aber wenn schon mit Webcam, dann mache ich das auch richtig.
Also ich muss ja mal ehrlich sagen, das Game sieht für mich sehr, sehr hart nach Resident Sleeper aus.
Ja, das sieht sehr Resident Sleeper-mäßig aus.
Strategie.
Wir brauchen mehr Echtzeit-Strategie-Spiele.
Das auf jeden Fall. Gibt es zu wenig von.
Die Römer sind am Start. Soll zumindest so aussehen.
Und die, oh Gott, Wikinger mit Hörnerhelm.
Oh nein, stopp's dann.
Moment.
Erst haben sie diese...
Warum haben die...
Okay, das hat ja nicht mal Ansatzweise mit dem...
Also das hat ja absolut nichts mit dem zu tun, wie das In-Game ausschaut.
Also absolut gar nicht.
Das sieht noch sehr rudimentär aus.
Was genau macht der da?
Wie das komplette Concept-Art-Zeug...
Oh, das ist ja keine Concept-Art.
Wie das komplette Art-Geschichten nichts mit dem Game zu tun hat.
Das muss der erst mal schaffen.
Ähm.
Malkyrs Interactive Card Game.
Ist das Hearthstone Reloaded 25.0?
Es gibt so viele Hearthstone-Clones.
Brauchen wir da wirklich noch einen?
Oh, boah.
Okay, das muss irgendwas haben.
Sonst hätten das nicht so viele Leute gebackt.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Okay, neue WoW-Trailer.
Ja, es könnte 1 zu 1 irgendwie in der Hearthstone-Geschichte sein.
Sieht schon so aus.
Oh.
Warum haben da so viele gebackt?
Moment, ich glaube, ich weiß, was das wird.
Das ist ein Offline-Game, oder?
Ja, das ist ein Offline-Game.
Malkyrs ist ein neues Spiel, das Videogame und echte Trading-Karten macht.
Um eine Karte zu spielen, ist es einfach.
Einfach auf einem Leser-Device legen, damit sie auf dem Bildschirm erscheint.
So kann man die wunderschönen Arten unserer Karten und die Vorteile von Online-Gaming genießen.
Dass da nicht schon früher einer drauf gekommen ist.
Das hätten zum Beispiel die Magic-Dudes machen können.
Die hätten ihre Karten irgendwie RFID-Chips verpassen können, dann kannst du online mitspielen.
Dann verkaufst du in echt Karten und...
Warum sind denn dann die Großen noch nicht früher drauf gekommen?
Und warum ist Blizzard noch nicht auf die Idee gekommen, Hearthstone-Karten rauszuhauen?
Ich meine, Hearthstone kannst du offline nicht spielen, aber...
Du kannst Karten eigentlich gelesen.
So.
Oh, French.
Oh, jo, jo, jo, jo.
Game-Mods.
Die sagen das irgendwie so.
Ich kann keinen Französisch.
Ich kann keinen Französisch nachmachen.
Ich weiß nur, dass Franzosen viele Wörter immer gerne einfranzösischen.
Und dann hat mal irgendein Franzose zu mir gesagt, anstatt Frischard, hat er gesagt Frischarde.
Und da war es vorbei.
Das übertreibt es halt.
Das ist schon wieder der gleiche Typ.
Wie oft hatten der das Game drin?
Das hatten wir doch vorher schon mal.
Oder?
Ne, das war was anderes.
Das sieht aber verdächtig, verdächtig ähnlich aus.
Stimmt, Skylanders gab es.
Ja, da habe ich jetzt gar nicht dran gedacht.
Hast du denn Super Mario 64 Fan Remake gesehen?
Das ist...
Wenn das schon ein bisschen her ist, habe ich das gesehen, ja.
Das ist der, der das erste Level nachgebaut hat, oder?
Oder gibt es noch mehr?
Es gibt saumäßig viele Mario 64 Teile in neueren Engines Remaked.
Weil es einfach ein Game ist, das viele Leute beeinflusst hat.
Das gibt es voll, ist YouTube voll damit.
Ein Game, was wirklich davon profitiert ist, also jetzt nicht von Remaken, sondern von Enhancen,
ist Mario Galaxy.
Mario Galaxy im Emulator mit besseren Texturen und mehr Effekten und so.
Das sieht wirklich nice aus.
Das Game sah nämlich viel besser aus, als sie Wii letztendlich hergegeben hat.
Okay, was war letztendlich... Frogvale.
Ist schon finanziert.
Nein, ist nicht, die Hälfte.
So diese...
Manche Währungen sehen so viel aus, irgendwie.
Und dann sind es am Ende, sind es dann halt 1000 Euro.
Texturen werden zu teuer.
Frogvale is a PC game of...
Was?
...and must now support his family by driving a bus.
This involves memorizing routes, driving the efficiency while...
Der Bus, der Bus-Emulator nur in... hässlich.
...I started this game partly inspired by liberty-taking bus drivers in my city.
...and how they usually have to do a lot of...
...working on the game only during my free time while also working a full-time job makes for slow development.
So what I aim...
...now six months is not a huge amount of time...
Ich meine, nichts gegen minimalistische und stylische Grafik, ja.
Aber ich finde nicht, dass dieser minimalistische Grafikstil stylisch ist.
...but I already have the main systems of the game in place.
The main things that are...
...das sind irgendwelche...
...eckigen...
...plops...
...Project...
...Weep...
...keine Ahnung...
...kenn ich nicht...
...Project...
...Medizinball...
...ich...
...erkenne nicht, was das sein soll...
...sieht aus wie Project Medizinball, oder?
...mhm...
...alles klar...
...woah...
...er spawnt nen Gegner...
...er schlägt nen Gegner an und der Gegner stirbt.
Das ist ding.
soak.
Ui.
Das ist- Das ist mega intenz.
Ultra intenz.
126 Chambord Street.
Horror Game.
Wir hatten heute erstaunlich wenig Horror Games.
Es ruckelt.
Zhao filiponne...
Blaufilter.
Battlefield 3...
...Blaubfilter...
Es ruckelt wieder?
Okay...
...quasi so nen...
Wie heißt das? Amnesia-Style-Ding.
Was ja überhaupt nicht mein Fall ist.
Naja.
Das sieht mir eher aus wie Horror.
Gewollt, aber nicht gekonnt.
Chaos, Roguelike, RPG, Early Footage.
Heute hat es uns minimalistische Grafik aber echt angetan.
Was zum...
What the fuck?
Dieser Sound, dieser Sound, das ist als würde es schleifen.
Oh, jetzt hat er abgegradet.
Hat gelootet, jetzt werden sie geowned.
Oh, krasses Immersive-Kampfsystem.
Was machen die Gegner eigentlich?
Sind die komplett unfähig?
Und warum sterben die nicht?
Was ist das?
Also manche Gameszenen wirklich, da weiß ich immer nicht, sind die absichtlich so komisch oder...
Oder ist es einfach ungewollt, ja?
Geil.
Toll.
3000 Euro, also wenn euch das zusagt, ja.
Bam.
Ich hoffe nicht, dass es wieder eine Visual Novel ist.
Ja.
Ja, und weiter?
Oh, es sieht nach RPG Maker aus.
Das ist ein RPG Maker Game.
Oder was meint ihr, es sieht aus wie RPG Maker.
Das ist Homewrecker RPG Maker.
Das ist sowas von RPG Maker.
Man könnte ja ein bisschen was zeigen.
Ja. Nope.
Math Commander.
Das erinnert mich daran, dass wir noch
Haftbefehl Features, nein,
Till Lindemann Features Haftbefehl gucken müssen.
Der Mathe Commander.
Die hässlichsten Asteroiden,
die ich je gesehen habe.
What?
Was sehe ich da wieder? Es kotzt.
Es hat irgendwas ausgekotzt gerade.
Ach, das ist der Raketenantrieb.
Ich habe gedacht, das komische Viech
speit irgendwas aus.
Ja, das soll man rechnen lernen.
Wisst ihr, was ich an der Grafik
heutzutage cool finde?
Das war nämlich gerade so eine Einstellung mit der Kamera.
Das hier, wenn man das so sieht,
das könnte aus irgendeinem Game sein.
Also wenn man
so ohne Kontext
drumherum, wenn man es heute
realistisch machen will, sieht das wirklich
ziemlich gut aus schon. Aber das ist halt echt jetzt.
Okay, es ist ein
Mathe-Spiel.
Okay, Pädagogik,
Bildungsauftrag, FPS am Start.
Wenn ihr das backen wollt, haut rein.
Roots the Video Game.
Ihhh.
Man kann Pixel auch in schön machen.
Man kann Pixel
auch in schön machen. Das ist nicht schön.
Das sieht...
Oh, Voice Acting.
Supreme.
Voice Acting des...
Boah.
Poggers.
Okay, für den war keine Stimme mehr übrig.
Oh man.
Cringe. Anfall.
Was zum Teufel ist das?
Was ist mit der Kamera?
Hat da jemand, der in der Nachbarschaft wohnt,
mal einen Satz gesprochen, oder was?
Amore. Yes.
So einfach ist es.
Ich habe keinen
Flassenschimmer, auf was es geht.
Was?
Das macht dich echt
im Kopf verrückt, manche Kickstarter-Projekte.
Okay, was haben wir als nächstes?
Cubes.
One on one online.
Game.
Zu scrollen, Snape mit Würfeln oder sowas.
Das ist wie aus Mario Galaxy, diese Level, wo das runterfällt, wo man drauf war.
Cubes.
Es sieht mir sehr langweilig aus.
Hi guys.
Das wird wahrscheinlich nicht der nächste Online-Competitive-Hit werden.
Wisbo, hatten wir das nicht eben schon?
Sieht aus wie ein MMO von 1995.
Äh, ha?
Control Epic Spellcasters, jawoll.
Moment.
Ich dachte, der Anfang ist das Game.
Aber das ist das Game.
Ähm.
Man scheint sich zumindest ansatzweise was bei gedacht zu haben bei dem Spellsystem.
Es sieht aber mega langweilig aus.
Es sieht mega langweilig aus.
Hotplate, ja.
Okay, wenn euch das angesprochen hat.
So.
Ne?
Malum.
Ah, eben, eben, Snake mit Würfeln und jetzt richtiges Snake.
Snake Enhanced.
Snake HD Edition.
Jetzt mit, äh, Levels, die irgendwie anders aussehen.
Okay, es ist, es ist Snake im Puzzle-Modus.
Mit einem FPS.
Ne, ich glaube, es ist so eine Art rundenbasiertes Game.
Das läuft nicht vorwärts, bis man sich bewegt.
Es sieht aber immer eine minimalistische Grafik in Ehren, aber das könnte sogar ich malen und ich kann es überhaupt nicht malen.
Wenn ich ein Game machen würde, 2D, dann würde das wahrscheinlich optisch ungefähr so aussehen.
Das ist jetzt aber nichts Gutes.
Oh, getrackt.
Ich weiß nicht.
Kingdom Ascent.
Oh, oh, halbe Million.
Jetzt bin ich, jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Jetzt will ich mal was sehen.
Es wurde auch schon gebackt.
Was ist das?
Es ist ein first, first player guided free to play game based on game system developed for Game of Thrones, äh, was?
Okay.
Zeige Gameplay, please.
Gameplay.
Die Kickstarter-Videos sind heute so am abkacken.
Gibt's da unten Video?
Er freut sich.
Okay.
Weiß nicht.
Vielleicht.
Was ist das?
Game of Thrones Ascent.
Hab ich schon nie gehört.
Highly popular game engine.
Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Was soll das sein?
Das ist Browser Game oder was?
Ja.
Geil.
Game of Thrones Browser Game.
Highly, highly Dings Engine.
Ja, super.
Das haben wir gebraucht.
Ähm.
Chaos FPS.
PC Game Multiplatt.
Ich ahne Schreckliches.
Ich ahne Schreckliches, wenn ich das schon sehe.
Was?
Erzählt uns erstmal.
Das Game wird definitiv nicht so aussehen, wie man jetzt hier im Trailer sieht.
Da ist natürlich die Frage.
Warum macht er den Trailer so?
Sollte man nicht einfach als Grundlage schon mal das nehmen, was es später auch werden soll?
Das sieht ja grausam aus.
Was ist denn das?
Oh Mann.
Mann, das tut weh.
Mann, das tut echt weh, wenn man es sieht.
Das ist dieses komische Alien da.
Das hätte ich aufmalen können.
Und das ist kein Kompliment, ja?
Wenn ich was malen könnte, heißt das, es ist in der Regel schlecht.
Das Haus ist irgendwie ein bisschen unförmig.
Ich habe keinen blassen Schimmer, was ich hier eigentlich sehe gerade.
Movie Maker Paint.
We won't disappoint.
Ich glaube halt nicht, dass das was wird.
Er will das Game in Unreal 4 danach machen, habe ich schon mal gesehen.
Okay.
Rocket Ghost Aiden.
Oder AI Dan.
Kickstarter Starts.
Nice.
Schön, dass wir auf Kickstarter sind.
Also ihr wisst ja, dass ich ein Fan von solchen Soundtracks bin.
Und wir hatten heute schon ein paar Spiele, wo ich gesagt habe, das Spiel würde ich mir nicht kaufen, aber den Soundtrack.
Bis auf ein bisschen was Melodisches habe ich jetzt da noch nichts rausgehört.
Was sich irgendwie harmonisch anhören würde.
Außer Gebrumme.
Was soll das von allem sein?
Und was soll das von allem sein?
Dieses Ding kommt Feuer aus dem Arsch.
Komm!
Das fliegt!
Feuer aus dem Arsch ... fliegt es hoch!
conjugate
wieder Survival. Das letzte Mal hatten wir aber deutlich mehr Battle-Royale-Games. Moins
Baselord 09. Hat da wieder eine Unreal-Engine installiert und eine Map gemacht und ein paar
Bäume draufgestellt. Bisschen Speedtree am Start. Wobei die Bäume sehen sich teilweise
schon ein bisschen ähnlich. Eher nicht Speedtree, eher Copy-Paste-Tree. Test-Demo-Scene. Okay,
das heißt Wald. Okay, und wo ist jetzt der Survival-Aspekt davon? Ein Hirsch aus dem
Asset-Store. Oh, krass, Animation. Aha, Demo. Impossible Dungeon Respawn.
Okay, wir hatten ja heute schon minimalistische Grafik und minimalistischere Grafik. Jetzt
haben wir minimalistische Grafik mit nur einer Farbe. Man kann es immer noch toppen. Ein
sexy Female Elf. Oh, dass wir das die Feministen hören. Ja. Hallo, kommt da noch was? Moment,
ist das nur Text? Okay, ist es Text. Nein, kein Video. Smash My Polygons. Also im Vergleich
zum letzten Mal war heute wirklich zum größten Teil Crap.
Oder? Es waren zwei, drei Sachen, wo man sagen könnte, ja, ganz okay. Aber der Rest war wirklich
Crap. Das ist so Just Cause für Arme. Was ist das schon wieder? Man kann Luftballons an die Leute
dranhängen und dann schweben sie. Ja, okay. Schön. Good Job. Und dann hängen sie an der Decke. Und
dann?
Jetzt tut man nicht so, als hättest du das selbst gemacht. Da zeigt das nämlich so, als hätte er das
selbst gemacht. Er hat es überhaupt nicht selbst gemacht. Den Schatten. Das ist Standard. Das ist
schon, das ist schon dabei. Das muss man heutzutage nicht mehr selbst machen. Das sieht... Was ist das
wieder für ein Krempel, ey? Weg. Shades of Light. Nicht Shades of Grey, Shades of Light. Was? Bei den
meisten Videos heute check ich überhaupt nicht, was ich überhaupt zu Gesicht bekomme. Wenigstens klitscht das
Haar nicht in den Boden rein, sondern nur in die Pflanze dahinter. Okay. Leute, ich glaube, es reicht für heute. Es wird ja
immer, es wird ja nicht besser, es wird ja immer nur schlimmer, wenn ich mir das hier schon angucke. Es wird schon, es wird immer
schlimmer. Ich glaube, wir machen jetzt Schluss. Ich glaube, wir machen Schluss für heute. Oh nee, wir müssen noch, wir müssen
noch Haftbefehl angucken. Ich will eigentlich überhaupt nicht. Ich weiß, dass mich das jetzt schon wieder aufregen wird, wenn ich
den Graben sehe, weil es wahrscheinlich total mies ist. Müssen wir uns jetzt wirklich Till Lindemann Haftbefehl angucken, ja?
Nein, müssen wir nicht. Sehr gut. Mache ich. Dann lasse ich es bleiben. Ihr seid, ihr seid ein netter Chat. Nein, ein nicer Chat. Ein sehr
nicer Chat. Warum hättest du es machen müssen? Ja, müssen muss ich gar nichts. Morgen ist der letzte Tag, Max. Für was? Der letzte Tag? Ich hab schon was.
Ich hab schon was.
Und zwar, ich zeige euch das mal, was ich hab, was ich gekauft hab. Das da. Das kommt bei Mädels mit Sicherheit gut an. Mädels haben immer kalte
Füße, wobei das sieht nicht so aus wie das, was ich gekauft hab. Nee, nee, ich glaub nicht, dass ihr zuschaut. Das sieht nicht so aus, was ich gekauft hab.
Die, die ich gekauft hab, hatten eine deutlich dickere Sohle und egal, aber sowas in der Richtung hab ich gekauft.
So, jetzt wisst ihr das auch. Gut, Leute, haben wir Schluss. War nice, dass ihr dabei wart. Danke für die Follows. Ich guck mal, wenn wir hier alles jetzt am Start haben.
Wenn die Seite lädt. Jetzt muss ich erstmal mit Twitch log in, weil er das schon seit gestern, oh, wieder vergessen hat. Also, danke für die Follows.
Misharo, Morface, KissDHD, AkisaFDW, TestoMorris, Storm.
Gott. So, mehr seh ich nicht mehr. Die Rest, die anderen sind von gestern. Vielleicht waren das heute auch alle. Geh ich schon mal von aus.
Ja.
Schön, dass ihr dabei gewesen seid. Wir machen an der Stelle Schluss. Und, äh, vielleicht sehen wir uns ja morgen schon wieder. Bis dann. See you.